J'aimerais que tu fasses une vidéo...
Un truc vraiment pourri
par exemple tu pourrais.... heu.... prendre les ondes de radio comme thème de vidéo et si elle dépasse
heu.... un million de vues je fais trois fois ta promo
Mesdames et messieurs bonjour et bienvenue dans cette vidéo
écoutez récemment j'ai eu envie
tu sais un peu comme une inspiration ultime de faire une vidéo qui allait parlé des ondes radio.
..du freestyle complètement !
On discute un peu des ondes radio
J'ai une poupée vaudou à l'effigie de Guillaume Play qu'on pourra planter un petit peu..
Ça me paraît vraiment un bon programme
Et après on pourrait essayer de pirater un peu les ondes radio qu'est-ce que t'en penses ?
De parler ouais un peu sécurité onde radio
Ouais !
J'aimerais si tu le veux bien, commencer par parler du rapport qu'il y a entre le mentalisme et les ondes radio..
voilà ça c'est fait (rires)
Ce chapitre là est clôt maintenant
Déjà de base en fait une onde radio enfin une onde
il faut imaginer une oscillation comme un pendule qui oscille sauf qu'il faut imaginer en fait que la vibration de cette oscillation
elle quitte son point de départ pour continuer à avancer.
Donc elle va osciller
comme une flaque enfin comme un aimant tu vois
exactement comme un caillou dans une mare la base de ce qu'est une onde radio
C'est hyper simple finalement
Donc c'est bon ! Salut !
Alors on pourrait rentrer dans des détails très techniques du style la vitesse, la longueur d'onde, la fréquence
Ouais, d'ailleurs
la vitesse est égale à la longueur d'onde fois la fréquence
il n'en restait plus qu'un donc on est bon
Mais cette vidéo deviendrai vite très relou
alors heureusement on a trouvé des petits trucs un petit peu plus
croustillants n'est ce pas à vous dire
Par exemple, la fréquence en fait c'est un petit peu comme un canal de diffusion on va dire
telle radio c'est sur telle fréquence telle radio
Il ya même des fréquences comme ça qui sont réservées ou allouer, voilà il y a une loi
et justement les GSM c'est pas le même que les fréquences radio etc etc
mais à chaque fois on parle bien de la fréquence de ça
La fréquence de 3 hertz à 30 hertz
avec une longueur d'onde de 100 000 km à 10 000 km
est utilisée pourquoi par exemple ? Est-ce que tu as une idée ?
3 Hertz
3 Hertz c'est tout petit
très très petit
C'est l'EBF, c'est l'Extrêmement Basses Fréquences
OK donc pas micro-ondes encore plus petit
Ouais
Eh bien écoute, c'est une bonne question
C'est pour des trucs naturels ? non ?
oui exactement pour les détections des phénomènes naturels
Bravo !
Ce mec est incroyable !
D'ailleurs il ya aussi une détection des phénomènes naturels à l'ultra basses fréquence
qui est de 300 Hertz à 30 Hertz aussi
Genre les super grandes vagues
Alors que la radiodiffusion, elle
c'est de 3 mégahertz à 30 mégahertz
Intéressant n'est-ce pas ?
On va peut-être pas en faire d'autres
Ah si, tu parlais des micro ondes, les micros ondes c'est comme
les réseaux privés le wifi etc..
C'est de 3 Gigahertz tu as 30 Gigahertz
avec une longueur d'onde très courte aussi
Ça marche
Aaahhh on a bien fait de se s'abonner à Fabien Olicard !
Les longueurs d'onde et les fréquences en fait, elle nous donnent une réalité
Ça, nous c'est notre réalité tu vois.
Une portion de réalité..
Ce qu'on peut entendre, ce qu'on peut voir, ce qu'on peut ressentir
c'est notre réalité à nous mais c'est pas la réalité complète
et par exemple genre t'as pas la même réalité qu'un vieux
parce qu'il ne va pas entendre les ultrasons enfin les petits sons, les trucs comme ça
Bien sûr et puis et puis encore moins que ton chien
ou ta chauve-souris ou...
t'as une chauve-souris ?
Oui.. et plein
Maintenant je vais vous parler d'une anecdote un petit peu rigolote qui s'est passé le 18 juillet 2017 si je dis pas de bêtises..
Je prends mon texte pour pas dire de bêtises parce que on scripte ce genre de vidéos-là
C'est clair, on maîtrise pas..
Les astronomes américains de l'observatoire d'Arecibo qui se trouve... (chuchote : à Porto Rico)
A Porto Rico !
Bravo ! ont capté des ondes radio provenant de ross 128 qui est une naine rouge
ils cherchaient autour de cette naine rouge des exoplanètes
ya des petits extraterrestres là-bas
C'est le fantasme ! T'as tous les mecs qui sont en train d'écouter NRJ justement
C'est ça ils écoutent Guillaume Pley
Donc les naines rouges évidemment ça n'émet pas des ondes radio ils essaient en fait d'éliminer
les hypothèses les unes après les autres pour voir à quel moment donné..
..à quel moment on tombe sur un petit bonhomme vert
Ouais c'est ça
On pourrait avoir une origine humaine
locale par des instruments sur terre mais ça pourrait aussi produit par des satellites qui communiquent avec la Terre pour transmettre leurs données
A priori, le signal détecté ne correspond pas à ce qu'on observe avec les satellites habituellement, les nôtres,
mais on peut pas totalement l'exclure
T'as vu le suspense qui se créé
Attends mais quand est-ce qu'on sait ?
En fait l'hypothèse la plus probable
c'est que la source des ondes radio serait plus lointaine dans l'univers et dans le temps que cet endroit là où ils les ont capté
Ce serait une simple coïncidence qu'elle semble venir de cette planète-là par rapport à sa trajectoire
parce que c'est pas très loin, c'est à 11 années-lumières
Ca va, je fais ça tous les matins de toute façon donc c'est vrai que..
Mais il y a une hypothèse
qui est assez probable qui pense que ça vient de plus loin que ça
De plus loin dans la distance et donc dans le temps du coup
Alors là ouais ils ont découvert ça au mois de Juillet mais pour l'instant réellement on sait pas
ils sont en train de chercher
c'est le principe des chercheurs d'ailleurs ils sont en train de rechercher l'origine
mais on ne sait pas et je vous informerais
Restez connecté à Radio Fabien !
Et donc une transition hyper logique suite à ça
Hein je propose qu'on termine avec notre petite expérience
Bah ouais  et puis écoute, on peut peut-être parler des radios pirates et tout
Ah oui mais alors ça c'est toi qui va nous en parler
Ouais, en France on peut pas émettre sur n'importe quelle onde radio
c'est déterminé donc c'est légiféré
Ouais
Et on va dire que NRJ par exemple, c'est 100.3 ou un truc comme ça..
Si vous êtes un petit malin et que vous avez un petit émetteur
Eh bah on risque pas mal en France si on émet sur une fréquence qui ne nous est pas destinée
donc il faut faire très attention à ça
Alors là ce que j'ai ici c'est un tout petit émetteur qu'on va essayer là tout de suite avec Fabien
c'est un petit émetteur qui peut avoir une utilité tout en restant dans le cadre de la loi bien entendu
je sais pas par exemple vous êtes dans une voiture
mais vous n'avez pas de prise jack pour mettre votre musique
vous achetez ce petit machin, vous le branchez dans votre dans votre téléphone
et puis vous allumez la radio et la fréquence
Et tu mets la même fréquence sur la radio
C'est ça. Là où il y a la petite fréquence on choisi un truc où il y a personne bien entendu parce que sinon
sinon on va emmerder les gens de la voiture à côté
On va donner des mauvaises idées là je crois
Ah c'est clair !
Ce qui est très drôle, c'est que quand Micode est arrivé avec ça
Quand il est arrivé avec ça je lui ait fait voir que j'en avais un depuis deux semaines !
Incroyable !
Faites pas les cons mais il faut savoir que ce qu'on appelle les radios pirates donc les radios qui
émettent sur une fréquence où ils ont pas l'autorisation notamment c'est quelque chose qui a vraiment un historique et qui était vachement
développés alors un petit peu moins maintenant mais je ne suis pas au courant c'était vachement développé par exemple la fin du siècle dernier
typiquement en angleterre il y avait deux radios il y avait la bbc et la radio
d'état a enfin s'etait les voilà les trucs principaux et à l'époque les jeunes ils voulaient écouter de la musique
du rock major c'était la pop culture à tout ça et ils pouvaient pas écouter ça la radio du coup bas
il y en à vide qui ont senti le filon
comme on dit et qu'ils ont créés ils ont créé une radio pirate où il y en a eu plusieurs en concurrence
en fait j'étais dans des petits bateaux genre dans la mer du nord il avait créé leurs petits pas dissipée dans les eaux internationales
pour pas se faire choper et puis ils balançaient du rock durant toute la journée
il se faisait une masse de pognon parce que du coup ils mettaient de pub c'est tout
je sais qu'il ya eu des films là dessus je me souviens alors j'ai aucune référence en tête mais je me souviens d'avoir vu des
films qui traitait un peu de cette culture de radio pirate ect
qui faisaient de leur garage qui se barre après pour faire dans le bateau parce qu'ils avaient été enlever de chez eux ect
c'est hyper intéressant
qui émettent tous une heure par mois et puis qui se barrent vite avant qu'ils se fassent chopaient donc voilà en terme
de sécurité n'y a pas grand chose à dire si vous allumez votre radio et qu'il ya un petit malin qui s'amusent à
piquer le a piqué NRJ pour moi il n'en rien dire des conneries voilà c'est pas une failles de sécurité c'est juste
c'est la guerre des ondes
après il ya tellement de trucs drôles à faire avec ça et on a tellement pas le droit d'insister à le faire
tellement interdit! des chose droles
Petit peu dans ma vraie avec un truc à très courte portée comme ça tu peux
diffusé un faux bulletin d'informations
tu vois juste à ton voisin ou à ta mère ou à ton pote parce que tu sais qu'il écoute cette radio là tout les matin
tu tu tu met a ta mère
votre fils a été élu le meilleur... ah grève des professeurs aujourd'hui
Putain
pourquoi j'avais pas ça! on se le test?
oui carrément alors j'ai branché la radio alors là les amis je suis en train de me caler sur nrj
à savoir 100.3
attend mais il est 20 heures c'est l'heure de Guillaume Pley c'est parfait! je connais pas en plus
les 20 heures passées c'est que l'émission de guillaume radio le monsieur guillaume pley qui m'a imposé faire cette vidéo
on va bientôt l'entendre une fois qu'on l'entendra je veux qu'on pirate NRJ pour mettre une de mes vidéos
pas le faire longtemps on va le faire un peu quand même
Ah ouais c'est un très bon micro sa c'est un micro de qualité
Sur nrj Guillaume Radio
heill c'est Guillaume radio en direct et en public
vas y
Fait attention à ce qu'on dit ça si on peut
je vais monter le son peut-etre! bin alors?
oui c'est une de mes vidéo et bin Guillaume? on t'entend plus
sur NRJ je me forme à
écoute pourtant on est on est on est toujours bien sûr la radio on est toujours bien chez toi bien cette fois vous regarde! BIZARRE
etc et en faire une chaîne l'année dernière qui s'appelle  ahahah
Commence et j'en profite aussi pour vous remerciera être déjà 200 a...
C'est cool m'ont tous les soirs fois sur les
Moins chers et vous pourrez choisir le placement voilà bientôt dix ans lanouf le moment
J'écoute guillaume radio je te coupe définitivement alors juste pour que vous sachiez
je vais vous mettre un extrait de ce qu'a dit guillaume quand il m'a donné cette contrainte là et si elle dépasse
un million de vues
je fais trois fois ta promo alors oui je n'ai pas beaucoup de vidéos qu'on fait un million de vues sur la chaîne mais
si vous voulez qu'on y fasse à l'envers complet je j'en appelle à la team mentalo on fera sa
à mes abonnés aussi alors (xD)
oui bah oui mais bien sûr c'est sûr qu'un merci micode d'avoir eu cette idée en vrai c'est lui qui a eu l'idée qu'on
fasse ça avec la radio merci beaucoup je crois que c'est le seul moment
De cette vidéo c'est vachement drôle n'empèche c'est excellent mais si mais c'est surtout très interdite
mais excellent mais maintenant on va on va casser ça et on va jeter sa
dans mon tiroir a moi
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à liker surtout la
partager à revenir la voir très régulièrement
on vas essayer de la pousser au million et si on arrive à la pousser au million je sais que guillaume tiendra son engagement
je pense qu'on se fera un petit truc directement
en direct de la radio et je lui imposerait à faire quelque chose avec vous on réfléchira à ça on n'en est pas là
pour l'instant on est à 0 vue puisqu'on est en train de tourner la vidéo
prenez le temps s'il vous plaît allez découvrir la chaîne de micode
c'est aujourd'hui que tu as sorti notre vidéo oui on a qu'une vidéo de dingue je vous jure que c'est vrai
c'est à dire que on en tremble encore ouais
on a fait ça juste avant je pas vous spoilier trop la vidéo mais le but c'était d'essayer
d'obtenir des informations confidentielles sur quelqu'un et c'est moi qui m'y suis collé et on était 2 il était très drôle
envie peu je vous dis pas je vous mets le lien de la vidéo dans la description comme ça vous irait voir merci beaucoup
ciao ciao
alors si c'est pas encore fait tu peux aussi d'abonnés à la chaîne
simplement en cliquant sur le petit rond que tu vois voilà juste ici c'est ce petit rond là ça marche depuis la tablette de téléphone
c'est extrêmement pratique il n'ya plus de répondre attendre allez-y abonnez vous c'est cool